[Risate]
[Musica]
e qual è il tuo colore preferito berlino
guarda il blu come i tuoi occhi
no non si basa berlino il ros e ti piace
che cos'è berlino che succede i knicks
che cos'è questo allarme sembra
provenire dal corridoio berlino è visto
qualcosa ma sei tu che cosa voi
e va beh in effetti un po fastidioso del
suo rumore mi sa che vado a controllare
né ciao ciao
[Musica]
vabbè andiamo a spegnere questo allarme
fastidioso
forse l'impostore aveva ragione scappare
da lui e non devo essere presa
altrimenti potrebbe eliminarmi ma dove
mai i pulsanti per trasmettere questo
allarme eccolo finalmente beh ora
speriamo che l'impostore se ne sia
andato via per sempre
qua c'è la mappa che cuoce una tasca
proviamo a fare questa task e vediamo se
succede qualcosa non è successo niente e
con persone ingredienti sul tavolino e
capisco devo completare le top per
trovare tutti gli ingredienti torniamo
in studio vediamo se c'è qualche altra
tasca per fortuna non sei nessuno in
studio quindi devo trovare tutti gli
ingredienti slime fare lo stream senza
che mi prenda l'impostore altrimenti mi
eliminerà e avrò perso la challenge voi
mi raccomando lasciato un bel mi piace
se questo video raggiunge i 20 mila
amiche accesi sarà una seconda parte in
cui magari potrei essere io l'impostore
cosa ne pensate
non mi seguite ancora su instagram
andati a seguirmi il nome anite stories
se volete seguitemi anche su tik tok il
nome sei premi tra tories ma ora
cerchiamo qualche tasto da completare
ho già il bicarbonato ecco una task
facilissima fare il download di questi
file di pasta semplice mentre scarica
vediamo
che al trattato marino pronto da quanto
tempo sei qui non ti avevo visto hai
visto l'impostore da qualche parte non
l'hai visto e comunque abitami 6 arriva
l'impostore ok non ti alleare con
l'impostore o non diventare impostori
anche tu mi raccomando di razzi per
questi bacini il task completata è
apparsa la ciotola e l'asfalto la zoomer
il muro il bari quindi abbiamo
bicarbonato spatola ciotola manca la
soluzione per lenti e la colla amici
qualche altra task qua il test della
card proviamo questa ok
inserisci la card eccola qua troppo
lento troppo veloce troppo lento upa
questa è la più fastidiosa di tutte
finalmente accettata ma dov'è
l'ingrediente non vedo niente qua
l'impostore provini
[Applauso]
c'è mancato poco che mi prendesse mi
avrebbe eliminato dal gioco il problema
è che non ho fatto in tempo a prendere
l'ingrediente dopo che ho completato la
task della card spero che non lo ruby
lui adesso potrebbe benissimo star lo
sta votando lui e ho lasciato anche gli
altri ingredienti in studio può essere
che lui li sta votando e facendo sparire
magari li ha espulsi e stanno viaggiando
nella spazio meglio che si sbrighiamo
vedremo se c'è qualche tasca qua ecco
un'altra task quella the cave le devo
collegare i colori dei fili quindi viola
con viola giallo con gialloblù con blu
insomma se avete visto lo scorso video
di among us nella vita reale sapete già
cosa devo fare o no ho sbagliato il
racco resto gli manca solo nino manera
questo era questo completata non è
ancora apparso l'ingrediente ancora tu
20 st
il mirino sul miglio la storia
l'impostore là dentro se lo merita
[Musica]
occhiuto l'impostore a chiave in camera
ora speriamo di poter completare
tranquillamente le tasche guardate ho
perso qualcosa è lì sotto la parte più
completato prima sono apparsi i glitter
rossi nel glitter argento è arrivato
anche marino e controllare e visto
berlino faremo lo slime glitterato con i
colori dell'impostore manca solo la
colla è la soluzione per 20 vediamo se
c'è qualche altra pasqua siamo magari
devo completare questa task
ecco qua bene non è comparso niente
buffa non ha funzionato
aspettate c'è qualcosa qua nell'ampolla
rossa liquidò anche se secondo te
merlino e soluzione berlanty dopo che ho
completata la tasca la soluzione per
lenti a porta in una delle ampolle
quella rossa come l'impostore bene manca
solo la colla e problema è che ho
completato la task dei fili elettrici ma
non ho fatto in tempo a prendere
l'ingrediente gradiente quindi sara lee
e sarà sicuramente la colla perché è
l'ultimo ingrediente che manca il
problema è che incamera 6 l'impostore
quindi devo per forza tornare in camera
e prendere la colla senza essere presa
altrimenti avrò fallito la missione cioè
la tra le zone idea
prendiamo qualcosa per difenderci e per
sconfiggere gli impostori
secondo voi questo potrebbe bastare per
sconfiggerlo
o almeno per tor dirlo e distrarlo un po
in modo da rubare la colla berlino tu
che ne pensi
potrebbe bastare questo per sconfiggere
l'impostore da ama non ti mangia perché
proviamo a dare qualche ricorda berlino
merlino sei bellissimo ma gli occhi il
colore del cielo grazie per questi
bazzini e perché ho detto che sei
bellissimo ma ci sei sempre bellissimi
nero è arrivato il momento di andare e
affrontare l'impostore una volta per
tutte a devo prendere la chiave per
aprire la porta
[Musica]
eccola con l'impostore funerali lascia
subito la colla berlino perché stai
divertendo l'impostore cena che tu
l'impostore spostati subito la colla
come si sa non lasci la colla sarà la
tua fine maggio per te io ti avevo
avvisato
[Musica]
tutto ora sbrighiamoci creiamo subito lo
strappo dell'impostore primo ingrediente
colla trasparente poi tantissimi glitter
wow guardato in quantità di terra per
quasi 1 slime natalizio
mettiamo anche glitter argentati
mescoliamo wow quota brilla bellissimo
soluzione per lenti per finire
bicarbonato ecco foto 16 ma è pronto
guardate che bello il super clip eroso
[Musica]
glitterato come le mie unghie piacciono
le mie unghie roma sport o no ma non
diamo molto victoza e mi dispiace per te
impostore ma io ho completato tutte le
tasche e quindi completato la missione
creato lo slime dell'impostore quindi
pecca di questo
ce l'abbiamo fatta abbiamo scolpito
l'impostore lasciate un mi piace per
altre challenge con l'impostore e ora vi
lascio con l'a4 caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
[Musica]